Welcome back everyone this will be my clea
video for doctor strange 2 the post credit
scene everybody wondering who she is what she's
going to be doing in the next couple of marvel
movies this big secret wars time runs out scenario
that they're teasing in that post-credits scene
literally while i was making this video marvel
released another clip with her featuring her
behind the scenes showing her costume off
and how they created the character
they're setting up a bunch of really big stuff
with her character so we'll break it all down
if you're brand new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos we're doing a
giveaway for disney plus memberships all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber and
just leave all your theories about clea on the
video careful for spoilers for the post credit
scene if you haven't seen it yet but in the
post-credits scene charlize theron shows up
as clea from the dark dimension telling doctor
strange that he just caused another incursion
he's going to come help her stop it like
she's really pissed off at what he's done
she asks if he's afraid and he's just really
excited like hell yes let's go stop this incursion
as if he knows exactly what he's doing he kind
of knows what's going on with the incursion
because of what reid richards is the fantastic
four said but he's really just learning what's
going on right now like he hasn't completely seen
the grand picture of everything he doesn't know
that all universes everywhere are in the middle
of just destroying each other the funny thing in
this scene being the fact that his third eye has
emerged like the physical expression of the eye of
agamotto which is just something that happens when
a sorcerer gains a certain level of magical power
the writer also confirmed that it's meant to be
one of the consequences of him reading from the
darkhold like he gains this ancient knowledge he
gains more power but he's also gained this small
taint with it like this potential that something
bad will happen to him eventually the darkhold
corrupted him a little bit not quite as corrupted
as sinister strange or quite as corrupted as
scarlet witch got during the movie but still just
a little bit corrupted the real funny moment here
being the clea doesn't call attention to his third
eye like oh yeah it's totally normal that humans
have third eyes on their foreheads all right let's
go then they cross the barrier between dimensions
entering the dark dimension again using one of the
portals that clea has opened with our own magical
power this is meant to be a big incursions time
runs out secret wars teaser for the next major
arc of marvel movies and disney plus series like
we just ended the infinity saga arc with the
avengers end game movie now we're entering the
secret wars saga with all these coming marvel
face 4 marvel phase 5 movies and that's what all
the incursions are about multiverse battle royale
starting with the kang multiverse war thank you
very much loki and sylvie but the post credit
scene is also meant to be a big doctor strange
three teaser for the next direct sequel movie so
clea is going to be a big character during doctor
strange 3. and she's just come to get doctor
strange's help saving her home universe she goes
way back to the classic comics but she's been a
relatively obscure character so when she showed up
in the movie a lot of casual fans were like wait a
minute who is this is she supposed to be a really
big deal yes clea is a very big deal she's been
doctor strange's true love interest for basically
her entire life in marvel comics eventually
they legit get married so it's like them
introducing doctor strange's wife to the movies
this is my life even though in the mcu they tried
to make christine palmer more of a big character
she was featured in the classic doctor strange
comics but the comics just in general aren't
that really concerned with the christine palmer
character like she's just not that big a deal
when you think of doctor strange getting it on
with someone usually marvel's go-to especially
in the comics has been the clea character but in
the mcu it seems like they're teasing some kind of
love triangle with this new christine palmer
variant from the illuminati's 838 universe
she will be back in doctor strange 3 as well
that was what that whole line i love you in every
universe was meant to imply like he still has this
longing for her but he's just met clea so this is
meant to be the first time that he's ever met the
clea character one of the cool things about her
character too is that she is way more powerful
than doctor strange because of her family line
so it's a big deal that they're introducing her
because they're introducing so many op characters
during marvel phase four she's dormammu's niece
she's the daughter of dormammu's twin sister umar
they're from a race called the fall teen beings
made a pure magical energy from another dimension
outside the main mcu dimension dormammu and
his sister are not originally from the dark
dimension either their race looks kind of like
them they can take humanoid form for instance
they can look more like clea if they want to
but dormammu just chooses to look like they do
in their pure form so they all tend to look kind
of like dormammu looks when dormammu and his twin
sister were born in this alternate dimension
they had some abnormalities so instead of just
consuming pure magical energy for sustenance like
the rest of their race they crave physical matter
and the rest of their people viewed this as a big
perversion so they basically booted them out of
their dimension into the main mcu universe in the
dark dimension now here's the big twist for those
of you asking if the dark dimension is meant to
be another dimension or just another universe
marvel's using it is just another universe they're
just calling it the dark dimension so in the mcu
the dark dimension is just like another part of
the multiverse and that's why it's threatened by
the incursions that are destroying the entire mcu
multiverse when you talk about other dimensions
it's sort of like another layer of reality like
the third dimension in the fourth dimension the
fifth dimension the multiverse mostly just
covers everything in the third dimension
so marvel's kind of hand waving and using a lot
of different terms to describe the same thing
when they arrived in the dark dimension it
wasn't an evil place like you saw during the
first doctor strange movie it was just another
universe inside the mcu when they arrived there
they taught the people who lived there ruled over
that place how to absorb other dimensions making
themself more powerful they kind of teased that
storyline during the first doctor strange movie
absorbing other universes clea was born to
dormammu's sister and the son of the original king
of that dark dimension before dormammu took over
so in the mcu clea is kind of a star-lord type of
character who's descended from this being of pure
power like star lord is half celestial so they're
not as powerful as their parents but clea has this
natural affinity for magic that regular humans
like doctor strange don't have magic comes to
her naturally kind of the way that magic comes to
scarlet witch without her having to learn spells
i'm not a witch i don't cast spells no one taught
me magic that's one of the bonuses that scarlet
witch gets from her chaos magic because she can
just think of something that she wants to do and
it winds up happening she doesn't need to read
spells to learn them out of a book like doctor
strange or other regular humans like wong do but
that's one of the reasons why clea is so powerful
why she can open portals between universes
like it's no big deal with her magic also they
explained that it's expressly forbidden according
to the rules of most of the magic that people
follow just because it's so dangerous and it could
potentially weaken the barrier between different
universes causing incursions and the eventual
destruction of all reality as reed richards says
so there are people that could probably do it if
they really wanted to but they're just afraid
to because of what might happen because of it
it's not really until you get to characters like
kang in the distant future who start doing it a
lot like traveling between different timelines
manipulating the multiverse in a really big way
just because their technology is so much more
advanced than what you have in present day just
to give you an idea for the power scaling though
cleo dormammu more powerful than doctor strange
but less powerful than beings like cathone god of
chaos the person who gives all of scarlet witch
her chaos magic when she was born so for instance
clea versus scarlet witch would be a really
awesome fight to see but i still think because
of all the extra power up she gets from her chaos
magic scarlet witch would ultimately be able
to stop clea the other big easter egg with the
way they're using her in the post-credits scene
here with the incursion secret wars time runs
out scenario wanting doctor strange's help saving
the dark dimension is that this scenario is a big
easter egg for the first time marvel introduced
her character in the comics clea debuted in the
early 60s in strange tales 126 which was also
the first story that they introduced dormammu in
so the first time doctor strange faced or mamu
is the first time that he met clea during that
story he travels to the dark dimension and winds
up meeting clea who's just fascinated with him and
winds up helping him try to get rid of dormammu
but during their fight doctor strange winds up
saving dormammu's life in helping save the dark
dimension from destruction from the mindless ones
so this will sound familiar they form a bargain
dormammu i've come to bargain and dormammu owes
doctor strange's solid so he allows clea to go
free so now clea has come to get doctor strange's
help to do something similar save dormammu's
life technically save the dark dimension from
being destroyed because it's her home so he'll
have to form another bargain with dormammu
i've come to bargain so in the mcu even though
clea is kind of like the sorcerer's supreme of
the dark dimension she hates her uncle dormammu
her mother umar she wants to get rid of them and
restore order in her universe because there's
like a whole race of regular people that live
in the dark dimension that she wants to protect
right now during time runs out as the incursions
are happening she needs as much power as possible
to stop the incursion from destroying the dark
dimension that's why she needs doctor strange's
help for his power and why they need dormammu's
power as well so heading into doctor strange
3 for example you have this big twist where
doctor strange has to form another bargain with
dormammu they help try to save his universe from
being destroyed and they have a temporary truce
in the face of full-blown secret wars while doctor
strange is learning who clea is and a relationship
starts developing between the two of them now when
most people think of clea they just think of
doctor strange's wife like oh they have this
romantic relationship but like i said they have
this weird thing going on with the variant of
christine palmer from the illuminati's universe
so just charting the timeline using iron man and
pepper potts is a benchmark for relationships
in the mcu if you remember they didn't really
get together at all until the end of iron man
2 and they didn't really get married till after
spider-man homecoming and they didn't really
have a kid together until avengers end game the
same movie that they wound up killing mcu iron man
during so if clea and doctor strange get together
in the mcu they probably wouldn't actually get
together till right before doctor strange probably
winds up sacrificing himself getting an iron man
style arc in this secret ward saga during the
movie several different characters confront
him with the idea that his 1 in 14 million
chance the idea that he thought was the only way
was not actually the only way there would have
been another way he could have sacrificed himself
he's been selfish this whole time why wasn't it
you to die so ultimately i think they're setting
him up on an iron man style arc while he will be
the one to fall on his sword but that'll happen
when a full-blown secret wars winds up happening
so if they wind up getting together in the mcu it
happened like right before he winds up sacrificing
himself so it's not like they're gonna get married
in the next marvel movie or anything like that
and marvel has this whole thing where they try
to find creative ways to keep them apart like
in the mc if you think about it she becomes the
ruler of the dark dimension so even if doctor
strange were to find a way to survive secret wars
they wouldn't really have time to be together
like right now in marvel comics they have this
whole death of doctor strange arc where clea
becomes the next sorcerer supreme doctor strange
winds up dying just another way to keep them apart
there was even one point in the comics where they
gave them their own spider-man one more day style
arc where they basically just erased all memory of
their relationship from clea's mind can i help you
hi um my name is peter parker but right now as
they start ramping up with the incursions things
start getting crazy cleo will be one of their most
powerful greatest allies but the majority of her
time you have to remember is spent trying to save
the dark dimension her home from the incursions
and from dormammu himself so they're trying to
tease that she'll work with the other avengers
the fantastic four the illuminati if they bring
a version of that team back anyone who winds up
surviving as they start actual secret wars on
whatever battle world winds up being but after
they fixed the multiverse she'd have to go back
to the dark dimension to spend most of her time
running that place doctor strange 3 will probably
wind up being released around the time that they
really head into a time runs out avengers 5 style
movie somewhere in between those which would be
like 2025 2026 so three years at the minimum for
doctor strange three maybe a little bit longer
depending so hopefully that explains who clea is
in the mcu specifically in these marvel movies
like this really powerful being descended from
being a pure magic who will be a big help to them
in their time runs out incursion secret war
scenario if you have any other questions about
what's going on with her character how marvel's
gonna use her or what's going on with doctor
strange three just post them in the comments below
i have a couple videos for x-men fantastic four
and other things from the movie plan so make
sure you have alerts enabled for my channel
congratulations master search you're the giveaway
winner for my last big marvel video please email
me on the about page of my channel so i can
get your contact details everyone click here
for my brand new doctor strange 2 iron man deleted
scene to learn what was going on with him during
the movie and click here for my full breakdown of
the entire movie with easter eggs for everything
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!